so this is a fund adducted reasoning
problem that's being forwarded around
the internet several people have
actually forwarded it to me and so I
thought it would be a fun thing to work
through the grammar isn't perfect but
the problem is a fun one
so it says Albert and Bernard justbe
could say became friends with Cheryl and
they wanted to know when her birthday is
Cheryl gives them a list of ten possible
dates and we have our ten dates here
Cheryl then tells Albert and Bernard
separately the month and the day of her
birthday respectively
just to make sure we're parsing that
sentence correctly she gives Albert she
tells Albert the month the month of her
birthday and she gives Bernard
she gives Bernard the day of her
birthday and I think we it's fair to
assume that Albert knows he's been given
the month and he knows that Bernards
been given the day and Bernards been
given the day and he knows that Albert
has been given the month and we should
also soom that they are good logicians
that they aren't they're going to do
very logical things and then we have
this dialogue Albert says I don't know
when Cheryl's birthday is but I know
that Bernard does not know - that's
fascinating and then Bernard says at
first I didn't know when Cheryl's
birthday is but now I know but now I
know fascinating and then Albert says
then I also know when Cheryl's birthday
is so when is Cheryl's birthday so like
always pause the video see if you can
work through this on your own it's a fun
problem to tackle and I'll give you a
little bit of a hint diagram out write
the information that each that Albert
knows and how does the world look from
Albert's point of view and then write
out how the world looks from Bernards
point of view and then tell us and then
think about what these what you can
deduce from these sentences so I'm
assuming you've had a go at it so let's
just do what I just said let's let's
diagram out the world from each of their
points of view so let's first from
Albert's point of view at a four Albert
so he's been given the month so he's
been given either May and if it's May he
says well then if it's May it's going to
be the actual day is going to be 15 16
or 7 15 16 or 19 15 16 or 19th he was
told you or he was told the month June
and if he was told the month of June
then he says well I don't know if the
date is 17 or 18 17 or 18 if he was told
the month of July if he was told July
he'd say well I don't know whether the
date is for the 14th or the 16th and if
he was told them onto August if he was
told the month August he'd be thinking
to himself well the dates either going
to be the 14th the 15th or the 17th now
let's think about the world from
Bernards point of view from Bernards
point of view he's been given the date
so if he was been given the date the
14th if he was told the 14th then he
would say all right let's see May is not
an option June wouldn't be an option
July would be an option and August would
be an option because there's just alive
14 and there's an August 14 there's no
May 14th or June 14th so he would say
well I'm not sure if he was told it was
the 14th then it's either going to be
July or August if he was told the 15th
then it would be lets see May would be
an option there's a May 15th year or
August would be an option there's no
June 15th of July 15th year so May May
or autist if he was told the 16th let's
see what are the options it could be May
there's a May 16th as one of the options
there's no June 16th there is a July
16th
so he'd say maybe it's July and there's
no August 16th either if he was told
it's a 17th if he was told it's the 17th
you could say well it's not gonna be May
there's no May 17th there is a June 17th
there is a June 17th there's no July
17th
but there is an August 17th so there is
an August there is I'll just write OGG
for short there is an August 17th and
then if he was told an 18th he would say
let's see there's no May 18th there is a
June 18th and I think that's the only
18th we have here so if he was told that
the Day is the 18th then he would know
he would know that the month is June and
if he was told that the day is the 19th
then up here the only 19th here is May
19th May May 19 so if Bernard Bernards
interesting if he was told the 18th or
the 19th then he would know what the
month is so with this out of the way and
if you're getting inspired I encourage
you to pause the video again and see if
you could work through these statements
but now let's work through the
statements so Albert says I don't know
when Cheryl's birthday is which makes
sense because no matter what month he's
been given here there's multiple options
for each of those months so it makes
sense that he doesn't know when Cheryl's
birthday is but I know I know that
Bernard does not know too so how could
he be so confident that Bernard does not
know too well Albert has the same
information that we have right over here
and and Albert says well look if the
date if Bernard was given an 18 or a 19
then he would he would know for sure
that Bernard does know the date so the
only way that he can feel confident the
only way that he can feel confident that
Bernard - the only way he could say I
know that Bernard does not know - means
that Albert knows that Bernard did not
get an 18th or 19th so another way to
translate this the statement is Bernard
Bernard did not get an 18th or 19th
Bernard not get 18th or or 19th now how
can Albert be so confident that Bernard
did not get an 18th or 19th well Albert
knows Albert knows the month Albert
knows the month and if you know if he's
so confident that Bernard did not get an
18th or 19th that's because he knows
it's not May or June
if the month that Albert got was May
then he would say well maybe he did get
a 19th year in which I can't couldn't
make this statement or if the month was
June well then 18th would have been a
possibility for what Bernard got and so
he wouldn't have been able to make this
statement here but because he says I
know that Bernard does not know - that
he the reason why he can say that is
because he knows it's not May or June so
we can rule out we can rule out May or
oonh so we can rule out we can rule out
the 18th the 19th year and we can also
rule out May or June now from Barnard
now from Bernards point of view we could
say look Albert was the owners why he
was able to make that statement is
because Albert knows that the month is
not May or June so let me rule out all
of the Mays and June's
so let me rule out June here let me rule
out let me rule out May over here now I
think you see where this is going
now Bernard and once again at any point
if you get so inspired please pause the
video and continue on with the deductive
reasoning that we have started all right
now Bernard says at first I don't or I
didn't know when Cheryl's birthday is
which is fair because it wasn't the 18th
or 19th which Albert are he knew but now
I know so now I know so before he didn't
know but now he knows so if now he knows
what are the possibilities what are what
are the possibilities going on here so
he knows if it's if the if the date he
was given is the 17th we've been able to
then he could deduce that hey the month
is now August if the date he was given
was the 16th the month that he could now
deduces July if the date he was given
was the 15th he could deduce August but
if the date he was given was 14th he
still wouldn't know the month what the
month is it could still be July or
August so we could rule out the 14th
because the 14th the date he was given
to the 14th he still wouldn't know but
he says now I do know so we could rule
out the 14th and once again we're
assuming Albert is hearing everything
Albert and Bernard they both could kind
of draw these diagrams out and so Albert
could now say ok look if if he now knows
then the date couldn't have been the
14th so then he rules out the 14th he
rules out the 14th so the stuff in
orange that I just did I got from this
statement there and then Albert says
then I also know when Cheryl's birthday
is so from Albert's point of view the
only way that he now knows what the
birthday is if the month he was given
was August he still has two options
there
but he says he now knows when Cheryl's
birthday is so it can't be August
because all the deductive reasoning
we've just found done if he was given
August then he would still not know
whether whether it was the 15th or 16th
but now that he knows it must be July
because if he was given the month July
there's only one option now for the date
so therefore the date must be July July
16 Albert must have been given July
Albert must have been given July and
Bernard must have been given must have
been given the 16th so Cheryl was born
on July 16th lots of fun